a U.S Department of Justice report says
the Minneapolis police killing of George
Floyd was part of a broader illegal
pattern of civil rights abuses we found
that MPD and the City of Minneapolis
engages in a pattern or practice of
using excessive force
unlawfully discriminating against black
and Native American people in
enforcement activities
violating the rights of people engaged
in protected speech
and discriminating against people with
behavioral disabilities the death of a
black man at the hands of Minneapolis
Police in 2020 led to a murder
conviction for then officer Derek
Chauvin say his name
in convictions of three other officers
who failed to intervene his loss is
still felt deeply by those who loved and
knew him and by many who did not
George Floyd should be alive today the
Justice Department investigation found
Floyd's death was not an isolated
incident the city and its Police
Department have agreed to negotiate a
consent decree with the doj requiring
the troubled Department to limit some
practices and end discrimination we
acknowledge the pain anger frustration
fear and sense of vulnerability that
many people in our community have
endured
I am here today on behalf of the MPD to
affirm our commitment to moving forward
together a bystander's disturbing video
of the Floyd killing set off Nationwide
civil rights protests that energized the
black lives matter movement
Minneapolis recently approved a series
of reforms including limiting officers
use of chemical irritants and banning
neck restraints like the one used on
Floyd we understand
that change is non-negotiable
progress can be painful and the
obstacles can be great
but we haven't led up in the three years
since the murder of George Floyd similar
decrees overseen by federal courts have
forced police overhauls in Chicago
Baltimore Ferguson Missouri and other
cities the Minneapolis report
intensifies a national Reckoning in
recent years on police human rights
abuses affecting black Americans John
hendren Al Jazeera